[Music]
events like the coronation tend to
provoke strong reactions some sat in the
rain for hours even days in fact just to
catch a glimpse of their new king but
there were others who went there to
protest to Signal their wish that the
monarchy be abolished and replaced with
an elected head of state and so it was
for the six members of pressure group
Republic or rather it would have been
had they not been arrested ahead of the
coronation under the public order act
which was itself only made law a handful
of days before several environmental
activists were also taken into custody
and three members of Westminster city
council's night Stars volunteers who'd
been handing out rape alarms in London's
West End so far no charges have been
brought all have been released without
charge the Met Police Commissioner has
described the arrest as unfortunate
others of course have used rather more
colorful language
but what exactly is the public order act
I will be hearing from a human rights
lawyer explaining just that plus a
former Chief Constable on the
difficulties of policing Civil
Disobedience and public disorder also an
academic on why Western democracies are
seemingly moving to restrict protest the
police itself is some extent against
possibility for them or they think it's
unclear is not going to be very easy to
apply but let's start shall we with the
journalist Mick Wright now he traveled
to London on the morning of the
coordination to report on the arrests of
those members of the group Republic
including its CEO Graham Smith Mick
found his way to a police station in
South London
I got into London by about midday and I
turned up and there were Republic guys
in yellow hoodies outside their station
but they were also just stop oil related
people there was a couple of other
non-affiliated kind of uh protest group
type people there that was it I knew
that there were 13 protesters in the
station Seven of whom were Republic and
uh the rest from various other groups
including uh just stop oil animal rising
and some other people that I didn't know
were in there uh which ended up being a
story that I broke and so what I was
doing is I I committed myself to staying
there for as long as they were in
custody which could have potentially
been 24 hours it ended up being 18 hours
but yeah it was a long day a lot of
McDonald's was eaten and it was a
complicated situation Republican been
talking with the police for four months
they had been very clear on what they
were going to do and when they arrived
in Trafalgar Square uh it was an ambush
there were 20 25 police officers there
and they had no intention of allowing
Graham or any of the other six members
of Republic from protesting of course
the Metropolitan Police deny that the
previous evening at 2 am when members of
night stars who are a metropolitan
police and Westminster Council
Affiliated volunteer group who give out
flip-flops and water and yes rape alarms
were picked up by the territorial
support group the protest Specialists
who searched them found that they had
rape alarms on them and arrested them
immediately now what was interesting did
they not identify themselves as being
the night Stars yeah they were wearing
pink jackets that have Metropolitan
Police and Westminster Council logos on
them and they also said this is who
we're from and the tsg said we've been
told to pick up anyone with these items
on them but of those that had been
arrested spent many many hours in a
police cell and then released without
charge of those that you spoke to what
was their response was it frustration
was it anger yeah it was a mixture um a
woman from the night Stars she came out
with floods of Tears she'd never been
arrested before and the experience of
being in a place with no windows You
Know spoken to Bruce Lee all that kind
of stuff do you see this as a direct
consequence of the changes that have
been made recently through the public
order bill now of course public order
act or do you just see this as something
that could well have happened even
without those changes to the law ah it's
a complicated question now I think it
was made easier by it because the police
had a lower burden of proof but I will
say that I I have been a reporter and a
journalist for 20 years at this point
I've been doing this professionally
since I was 19. I'm now 39 and I
reported on the student riots I reported
on all kinds of protests you know in the
kettling era the tsg I have always
behaved I believe in a in a very
heavy-handed and often violent way the
actors May made it easier the
Metropolitan Police have since said this
it was not Our intention to prevent
protest and whilst the vast masses of
the crowd were there to celebrate and
witness a once in a generation event it
is very clear a number of protests took
place across the footprint both before
during and after the event with no
police intervention any suggestion or
protest was prohibited is not correct
and that statement continues we regret
that those six people arrested were
unable to join The Wider group of
protesters in Trafalgar Square and
Elsewhere on the procession route
now some have identified the pace with
which the legislation was passed as part
of the problem Adam Wagner is a human
rights barrister
so the public order act came into Force
literally a day or two before the
coronation it's been on the agenda for
well since 2021 I think it was
originally a series of late amendments
to a previous act the policing and crime
act which were defeated in the Lords and
they were brought back as a specific
bill as a separate bill what the
government says is it deals with
protests that have been in the public
eye for the last few years and of course
very serious disruption to roads and to
city city centers so particularly
Extinction Rebellion just up oil
insulate Britain those sorts of protests
so that's the that's the stated aim of
it and it brings in a sort of raft of
new measures which criminalize things
that previously were either not against
the law or were not specifically
identified in the criminal law take us
through that list then because I think
for for a lot of people it will be
confusing that there was at least before
the public order act there was the
ability for protesters to cause problems
on on a massive scale but but they were
able to they were they were permitted
weren't they so things like blocking the
roads throwing a tomato soup a painting
breaking windows and those sorts of
things they were all illegal already you
know you you can there's an offense of
obstruction of the highway
um under the highways act 1980. you
cannot use violence um in any protest
it's always unlawful to use violence
it's not protected by human rights law
um and it's unlawful to to break things
and to destroy public property what this
bill does really is interferes with what
would otherwise previously have been
seen as non-violent peaceful but
disruptive protest so things like
blocking other entrances or the
protesting at the entrances of fracking
sites are now covered by the offensive
blocking of interrupting serious
disruptions and National infrastructure
and that's also covers roads things like
tunneling it's been an offense already
but now it's specifically covered by
this bill and then the one that's been
controversial over the last few days
because of the coronation was locking on
so this is the tactic which has been
used I mean certainly been used over a
long period the suffragettes were famous
Locker Runners you know they used to
used to chain themselves to fences in
public places and that sort of thing
which makes it harder for the police to
break up a protest if you're found to be
carrying gay a lock or a you know bike
lock or a role of duct tape or string
rope that sort of thing you could
potentially be arrested and prevented
from being in a in an area well tell us
a little bit more about the the freedom
that the police now enjoy to bring about
an end to protest because and I know
you're not alone in this but you have
been very critical you have expressed
deep concern about this piece of
legislation if you just think of a
particular situation so a protester
chaining themselves to um the front of a
of Parliament and stopping MPS getting
in now that would potentially be
unlawful anyway for various reasons but
but now that specific situation will be
covered and you might think oh well
that's very sensible but then you get
into the you if you start sort of
stepping back and think of the police
powers that they have they have powers
not just to unlock that person and then
prosecute them they have powers to go
and go and look for stop and search
large groups of individuals if they
suspect they are going to be carrying
equipment for locking up they can then
for 24 hours say have a or a fruit a few
hours they can go and search anybody
they want without suspicion who is
protesting and you can imagine how that
could very quickly start to look like
the police interfering with a with a
disrupting a protest because they want
to disrupt the protest and previously
that's a kind of Suspicion to stop and
search has only been used in areas where
there have been a where there's been a
reasonable belief of violent crime is
about to occur so you're treating p
protest like violent crime
another Power they have is something
called serious disruption prevention
orders this is another tactic that the
or another Power the police have had to
previously to deal with crime violent
criminals to deal with gang members and
to deal with people who have committed
serious crimes but now any protester who
has found more than I think it's twice
um they can guilty of a sort of protest
related offense and bearing in mind
they're very broad these offenses can be
that they can be ordered for say a year
not to enter any City centers or not to
associate with certain sort of
co-protest organizers
and and what happens if they breach that
well then they're in contempt of court
the court can put someone in prison for
over for up to two years or give them a
a huge fine for being in contempt of
court and and what this is all doing is
it's ratcheting up the the way that we
deal with disruptive protests disruptive
peaceful protest and it's really I think
it's really quite worrying just to
conclude in terms of the Liberties that
we enjoy in this country on an order of
significance to what extent has the
public order act limited or removed the
rights of the British public to to do
that which they have done since time
immemorial and make their opinions known
to their leaders
um I think it's I think it's actually
really quite a serious restriction and I
don't say that I'm not being
melodramatic now as I understand that
there are about over a hundred
protesters were sent to prison for you
know uh breaching various injunctions
for breaching criminal laws including
some of my own clients
um and I think that is a sign that we
are moving in a worrying Direction and
some people say well if you don't go to
prison you don't block roads you don't
um you don't try and prevent National
infrastructure projects like hs2 or
fracking or something like that
but my my question to them would be well
where would the Civil Rights Movement
the United States have been without
marching down the middle of major roads
and the thing that I really worry about
and I see this in my own work is that
the increase there's a sort of there's a
self-fulfilling prophecy because if you
make uh if you make sort of the the
population thing the protesters is a
risky thing you know I don't want to go
to a protest I might get arrested I
might get you know lose my job might end
up in a in a jail cell why would I want
to do that I just so that you know the
biggest impact you can have with as a
protester is to have a hundred thousand
people that is the ultimate Way of of of
getting your point opinion across but
instead they're going to be going for
more and more incendiary
um attention seeking things they're
going to be wanting to go to they're
going to be wanting to go to prison as a
sort of you know to prove a point
um and you're going to get more and more
people say oh well we need to really
control these protesters and it's like a
sort of centrifuge it will just get
faster and faster and more and more
extreme and that is bad for everybody
all of which rather begs the question
what then is the current state of our
right to protest to what extent has the
public order act diminished the ability
to dissent politicians pass the laws but
as always it falls to the police to make
important decisions in those often
difficult environments so Peter 5 was
Chief Constable of Greater Manchester
police
it's always been a challenging issue for
policing and the fact is you know you as
the as the police but particularly as a
chief Constable you do actually sit in
quite a crucial position between trying
to balance uh sometimes the concerns of
local community councils politicians
local businesses which are affected by a
protest and the people who want to
protest and the reality is those
protesters have to create some form of
disruption if their cause is going to
get any publicity so right the way
through you know certainly the last
three decades that has always been a
difficult balance but what we have
learned is that when you rush in
legislation to deal with a particular
set of tactics by a particular set of
protesters and you don't look very
closely at the definitions and where you
allow officers to act on suspicion and
then put pressure on them the trouble is
it then often does create these sorts of
situations where the balance is tipped
and people believe that police have gone
too far
um and as I say is in that context of
you know it's achieved comfortable I've
certainly got pressure from businesses
from politicians to use the law in a
particular way sometimes they themselves
didn't even understand that law but the
fact is I had a certain degree of
Independence to say no we will get the
balance right and I will balance you
know the needs of the protesters with
the needs of the community the trouble
is because of that greater political
pressure now and things like 24-hour
news and social media that room for
discretion
um for a chief constable and the police
on the ground has really narrowed and
Peter clearly you are independent of
mind I'm just wondering you mentioned
politicians putting pressure on Chief
constables and and others I would
imagine how does that pressure how is
that pressure manifested how does it is
it simply the case that someone picks up
a phone and and and shouts at the chief
Constable for five minutes yeah
sometimes it does you know I had to deal
with a particular situation in
Manchester in the city center of
Manchester which was essentially an
issue about what was happening in Gaza
at the time uh created huge emotions
between Jewish groups and Muslim groups
and I had various politicians
representing what you might call either
side uh trying to put pressure on me
calling me asking to meet with me giving
their interpretation of public order
legislation at that time which I
fundamentally disagreed with but the
fact was
um because I was a fairly experienced
Chief constable
um I could resist some of that
um and actually say no this is what I
think is the right thing to do not just
sometimes in terms of what the law says
and get that balance right between the
right to protest and disruption to the
community but also what's actually
operational operationally possible you
know for the officers on the ground what
we need to recognize is in our democracy
that fundamentally changes that balance
and I don't think people realize how
really important it is to British
democracy we've only got to look around
the world to see that policing around
the rest of the world
um is just used in a very political uh
often um really brutal way against
protests in this politically controlled
by dictators and National governments
thankfully we don't have that we have
separate police forces locally
accountable and operationally
independent Chief constables and over
recent years we've seen that eroded and
I think some politicians themselves
don't understand how critical that is
for all of us whatever side you're on
and how important it is to preserve that
and under understand that yeah I want to
talk about the police officers on the
ground the rank and fell those who will
actually be implementing the public
order right I mean I understand the
political pressure comes in a top-down
Direction but with a piece of
legislation that you yourself describe
as rushed and others have described as
as rushed how much opportunity do those
Rank and file police officers have to
get to grips with the legislation to
understand the legislation to know what
they are supposed to do and what they
are not permitted to do and no room at
all really to be quite honest in the
Practical uh aspects of day-to-day
policing
um you know this legislation this
particular legislation only came out a
few days before the coronation is quite
complex in its uh you know the
particular clause which has caused this
difficulty is a clause which gives the
police the right
um to seize any uh item which they
suspect may be used to lock on and
lock-on includes you know locking
yourself to a to a person to an object
to a thing whatever whatever you know
that's quite a complex thing to get your
head around and people don't often
understand that within each one of those
Clauses there are particular words that
need to be understood so I don't know
really how those offices are supposed to
make sense of that and it's what's
changed certainly over my time it's just
a sheer pace of legislation and I'd say
often rushed over Parliament and we see
it in this case because we've now got
politicians saying there needs to be a
review of that legislation well this is
only a few days after it was passed
through Parliament so actually what what
what went wrong with that scrutiny in
that process and why didn't they listen
to some of the voices that said this
this legislation is problematic what
then Peter is the state of the right to
protest currently in the UK I don't
think he's in a healthy State at all
um because of the weight of this
legislation this legislation creates
expectations on the police to act uh it
gives greater power in a way to
politicians and particular interest
groups to put pressure on the police to
take that action and put some police in
a very difficult issue in terms of
trying to interpret that and it's often
those front line officers that bear the
brunt then in terms of being accused on
lawful arrests
um you know illegal activity and
ultimately it's the confidence of the
police that gets eroded the government
has responded to some of the general
concerns raised by Sir Peter and others
he is the minister for Crime policing
and fire Chris philp speaking in
Parliament
the protests did happen and indeed there
is no question in principle or in any
legislation that the right to peaceful
protest is sacrosanct we have of course
in recent months seen that right for
peace to peaceful protest being
stretched into acts that are
deliberately disruptive where people
have sought to close down the M25
they've sought to close down the Streets
of London uh not so much as an act of
protest but to deliberately
inconvenience the public and that is
where we draw the line
still what's happening with the public
order act in the UK is a far from unique
and mirrored elsewhere
is Professor of international law at the
University of Portsmouth there's a lot
of pressure on the police
stations in the past the powers of the
police have been expanded to such an
extent that it's difficult for them as
well to know what exactly they should do
I've been working with some police
forces in interviewing them you know
asking them about their roles and how
they see themselves and I see actually
that there is a sort of crisis at the
moment a crisis a sort of three-fold
Crisis a crisis in terms of legitimacy a
crisis in terms of belonging and also
crisis in terms of trust by the public
so for the police it's very difficult to
understand whether they are legitimate
or not in applying certain measures
because the definition of these very
measures is often very blurred I suppose
that a lot of people are uneasy about
the public order act this is the country
of Magna Carta this is a country which
is not just spread human rights around
the world but but was involved in
creating the concept of Human Rights
how though has has public order policing
in this country got to this stage
because because it kind of happened
overnight there must have been a
direction of travel the public order act
in and of itself whilst it whilst making
a seismic changes that can't be the the
start and the end point of this you're
right I think it's very important to
step back it has not happened
in something like maybe two decades to
reach this stage and the UK is not an
isolated country it is something we
observe in a number of European
countries or maybe Western countries if
you wish so there are two main elements
or two main moments which have informed
and influenced this sort of policy
change the first obviously is the 911
the terrorist attack the second is the
coffee pandemic so let's get back to the
9 11. since the 911 a number of
democracies the US the UK France Germany
have adopted certainly more stricter
stricter laws and have adopted the idea
of exception as the norm so everything
if you wish becomes an exception we are
going to adopt this type of legislation
because it's exceptional terrorism is an
exceptional circumstances and the same
is true for kovid it was an exception
wasn't it the pandemic was so grave that
we had to take certain measures
legally somehow limiting our rights so
indeed this is a sort of pass that we
went through what then is the end point
of of changes like this in functional
democracies like like the United Kingdom
I mean I I see some people talking about
a slide into authoritarianism which
which to me seems slightly insulting to
those who truly do live in authoritarian
regimes we're not yet there luckily we
still have a very vibrant civilian
Society we have amazing legislation we
have courts we have police forces and
and again that's interesting to reflect
about upon the many different actors our
society is built in such a way that
democracy is very much embedded the
police itself is to some extent against
the new bill because they think that
it's too much responsibility for them or
they think it's unclear is not going to
be very easy to apply so we're not yet
there but what's the end of that of it
well it's difficult to say I think um a
change of government may be but also
stepping back and trying to reflect upon
the relationship we have have with these
non-democratic powers and the rule they
play in our economies and in our
political lives
my thanks to Mick Wright Adam Wagner sir
Peter Phi Laila shukrun and of course to
you for listening to the Sky News Daily
with me Neil Patterson this episode was
produced by soil aparicio our editor is
Philly Bond